[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date année
d'interdire l'écologie ne date pas des
années 70 comme on le croit ou 19e
siècle les britanniques étaient déjà
obsédé par la pollution et la première
enquête officielle sur le changement
climatique a eu lieu en france en 1821
je reçois aujourd'hui une historienne
c'est anne claude en brosse ronde rendu
est un historien charles françois
matthys avec stéphane à gimont et
alaixys brignon ils se sont mis à quatre
pour écrire une histoire des luttes pour
l'environnement qui paraît chez textuel
et qui court sur trois siècles du 18e au
20e trois siècles de combats deux
défaites mais aussi victoire un beau
livre de 300 pages comptant sans récit
sans date marquante très bien illustré
que l'on va fêter pendant toute cette
émission mais d'abord voici l'image que
vous avez choisie pour illustrer ce
début de xxième siècle and close
quelques heures présente alors c'est une
action d'extinction rébellion ce
collectif nouveau qui s'est formé en
france sur le modèle britannique
et qui illustre me semble-t-il une d une
des nouvelles modalités d'action menée
aujourd'hui par par les militants
écologistes
[Musique]
avec cette selle l'adoption de ce qui
n'est pas un sit-in mais un les in
pourrait-on dire et il a longé là il
faut bien regarder ils sont allongés
dans un liquide rouge qui est censé
figurer du sang est donc donné l'image
des destructions opérées par total et sa
politique de mise en valeur
un peu partout dans le monde
charles-françois le l'intérêt aussi de
cette image c'est qu'elle caractérise un
peu les luttes nouvelle d'aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que ce sont des jeunes
gens une jeune génération qui prend les
choses en main et qui se rebellent
contre l'ordre à qu'il y aurait été
imposé par ses aînés c'est aussi une
action qui s'opposent à une
multinationale dont il d'emblée prend
une dimension globale dans sa conception
delà de la lutte on est plus sur des
luttes locales de voisinage 10 on vit
vraiment sur une conception planétaire
du combat environnemental
est le dernier élément c'est alors ça se
voit peut-être pas ici mais la dimension
délocaliser en quelque sorte de ces
luttes qui se répandent qui sont
spontanés un peu partout dans le monde
et qui sont en quelque sorte
décentralisée qu'il n'y a pas une
structure centrale qu'il est qui les
organisent ici c'est un mouvement
relativement spontanée de cette
association aux moyennes dimensions
supplémentaires aussi par rapport à
toutes les luttes qu'on va voir vous
répertoriés dans votre livre c'est qu'il
ya le sentiment d'urgence c'était que la
fin du monde est censé à devenir très
très vite et que donc des mesures
beaucoup plus radical des comportements
plus extrêmes sont encouragées
oui vous avez tout à fait raison ce type
de collectif un peu nouveau bien qu'ils
s'inspirent de précédents d'aînés que
tel greenpeace est né à peu près au
moment où on a commencé d'utiliser
ponctuellement d'abord puis massivement
ensuite la notion d'urgence climatique
donc c'est bien pour répondre à cette
urgence qui me concerne d'ailleurs pas
que le climat mais aussi l'effondrement
de la biodiversité et c'est que ces
jeunes gens se mobilisent et bien
commençons
[Musique]
c'est donc au xviiie siècle d'après
votre livre le siècle des lumières que
s'ouvre l'ère des combats en faveur de
l'environnement et s'il fallait désigner
une figure tutélaire need vous ce serait
le philosophe jean jacques rousseau qui
paraît dès la page 19 de votre livre
alors pourquoi jean jacques rousseau ce
qu'il est une bonne illustration de
l'esprit des lumières d'une part et
qu'il en même temps il il opère une
espèce de ne pas de côté à l'égard de
celle de la philosophie des lumières qui
conçoit encore le l'homme comme étant
maître et possesseur de la nature et que
justement rousseau va suggérer de
d'établir un autre rapport avec le monde
des vivants et va s'inquiète est un des
premiers à s'inquiéter des destructions
opérées par les activités humaines sur
le milieu naturel oui les diverses
facettes de rousseau correspondent bien
ce rapport nouveau à l'environnement il
est naturaliste on s'intéresse on a un
regard scientifique sur la sur la nature
ce qui se conforte au xviiie siècle et
ils manifestent cette extériorité en
fait au monde naturel qui va être la
marque de la modernité c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a un regard esthétique sur
elle alors comme certains de ses
contemporains comme bernardin de saint
pierre par exemple et qui annonce en
quelque sorte le romantisme déjà par an
ses rêveries du promeneur solitaire par
exemple donc ce double mouvement
d'études scientifiques de regard
esthétique et de nostalgie d'un monde
détruit par déjà l'urbanisation pas
vraiment l'industrie chez lui plus le
monde moderne dans son ensemble
pose les fondements justement de ces
combats environnementaux alors ouais là
où j'ai été très étonné en lisant ce
livre c'est que dès 1829 on s'inquiète
déjà des modifications du climat et
essai c'est en france 1
alors ça répond d'abord à un phénomène
planétaire qui est l'éruption d'un
volcan en indonésie le tambour à en 1815
qui projette donc dé descendre un peu
partout dans l'atmosphère et entraîne
des perturbations climatiques dans le
monde entier notamment en europe où on
parle en 1816 d'un et et son soleil
d'ailleurs ça a des conséquences
culturelles puisque le poète byron va
écrire un un poème seulement magnifique
s'appelle darkness qui imaginent
justement la victoire des ténèbres sur
le monde et l'extinction de l'humanité
qui brûle tout ce qu'elle a les forêts
les maisons etc jusqu'à la dernière
cendres pour obtenir un petit peu de
chaleur et de lumière déjà la fin du
monde déjà la fin du monde exactement
donc un phénomène climatique fin des des
phénomènes climatiques perturbant disons
pour les européens suivis de pluies et
de sécheresse qui effectivement suscite
des inquiétudes et ses inquiétudes sont
reliés également à des études qui
avaient été faites dans les colonies
insulaire où on avait constaté à l'île
maurice à sainte-hélène que en coupant
trop de forêt ont perturbé les cycles de
l'eau on entre à n'être plus d'érosion
les pluies se faisait rare sur ces
territoires insulaires et des ingénieurs
des administrateurs français et
britanniques en avait conclu qu'il
fallait prendre soin des forêts donc
tout ça a mené en 1821 en fait une
commission sur le soleil divin su
tromper leur oui c'est qui qui a mené
quelques enquêtes comme ça envoyé des
questionnaires pour essayer de
déterminer les raisons de ces
changements climatiques sans grande
conséquence d'ailleurs sur le moment
mais est ce qu'on se trompait
complètement à l'époque où on est déjà
une vision assez assez juste de ce qui
ce qui peut ce qui est en train ou 12
qui peut se produire alors on ne
percevait pas bien sûr déjà un
changement climatique globale provoquée
par l'industrie sannois c'est beaucoup
trop c'est beaucoup trop tôt certains
étaient plutôt d'ailleurs dans une
pensée an plus tôt à la fin du xviiie
siècle une pensée du refroidissement à
venir delà de la terre pour diverses
raisons de thermodynamique donc on ne
pensait pas des perturbations au niveau
général en revanche on pense à des
perturbations au niveau local et en lien
donc plus avec le la déforestation cas
avec véritablement la pollution il ya
quelques penseurs déjà mais très isolés
qui percevaient
l'augmentation potentielle du co2 dans
l'atmosphère à la suite de l'utilisation
massive du charbon mais c'est vraiment
la fin du 19e siècle avec arrhenius que
on va corps et les climats et émissions
de carbone avant on y reviendra parce
que lui évidemment prix nobel de chimie
c'est le premier qui fait le lien mais
on voit bien que dès le début du 19e
siècle et ça va durer pendant tout le
19e siècle on se révolte contre les
nuisances industrielles 1
oui alors on se on se révolte souvent
localement ce sont des révoltes locales
qui sont liés alors on peut on peut
évoquer plusieurs exemples là je pense
précisément à l'installation d'une usine
à clermont ferrand qui ont suscité la
mobilisation du voisinage donc ce sont
des luttes locales
qui de l'individu qui s'inquiètent en
réalité alors d'abord pour leur santé
pour les faits que les différentes
émanations des industries locales
peuvent avoir sur leurs tifos et de la
jeunesse que c'était comme la fumée qui
sortait des laridés qu'on voit là un
c'était s'était pas aujourd'hui on a
plus on sait plus ce que c'est on n'est
pas que c'était dingue on ne sait plus
ce que c'est d'autre on le sait d'autant
moins que il n'ya plus de du sinn qui
dans les visionnent dans les villes
c'est ça elles ont toutes été déporté à
l'extérieur et donc ils s'inquiètent
pour leur santé bien sûr ils
s'inquiètent aussi parce que ça affecte
de leur mode de vie quotidien se dire
que c'est impossible de faire sécher du
linge dans le jardin parce qu'ils
étaient immédiatement salies et puis ils
s'inquiètent aussi et ça c'est pas
forcément là la plus noble des raisons
pour la valeur de leur bien et on le
voit bien à clermont ferrand les
mobilisations qui est au milieu du 19e
siècle vise au fond à
obtenir le départ des de l'industrie
pour pour pour que le bien immobilier ne
perdent pas de de valeur et soir
vendable c'est vrai que comme vous le
disiez c'est ces pollutions sont
extrêmes on n'imagine pas aujourd'hui
leur leur violence on a des témoignages
qui évoque par exemple au des usines de
soude là le fait que lorsque le vent
repoussait les fumées qui se dégageaient
des cheminées sur des champs de blé le
chant était brûlé en quelques minutes
ça ça donne quand même une idée de la de
là la nocivité en fait de ces de ses
émanations sans parler bien sûr où le
royaume uni notamment des nuages de
fumées provoquées par la combustion du
charbon aussi bien par les industries
d'ailleurs que par les doubles et les
intérieurs domestique et cette époque
les autorités
le politique est conscient qu'il ya un
problème où il donne systématiquement
raison aux industriels alors il est
conscient qu'il ya un problème et il
donne raison aux industries en france
par exemple le décret de 1810 était un
décret donc d'un pôle éolien qui impose
d enquête commodo incommodo donc
d'insalubrité sur l'installation de
certaines fabriques et cuisine qui sont
donc selon le degré de nocivité disons
elles ont ou pas le droit de s'installer
en ville est en fête ce décret va priver
en quelque sorte les tribunaux de tout
mot à dire qu'ils ont sur ces sur les
atteintes à la propriété à la santé etc
alors que c'était vers les tribunaux que
se tournaient les citadins auparavant la
saison voilà la saison l'autorisation de
l'administration sexologue voilà un peu
on peut s'opposer l'administration mais
ça prend plus de temps et l'ait soutenu
par le pouvoir politique justement qu'il
veut encourager l'industrie qui est
essentiel bien sûr au développement la
première association contre la
maltraitance des animaux c'est à londres
en 1824 ça suit de très peu en france en
1845 ce sera la spa ça n'est pas on n'a
pas attendu la non plus la fin du xxème
siècle pour penser que les animaux
n'étaient pas juste des objets on sait
qu'ils peuvent souffrir on ne veut pas
qu'ils souffrent sur la voie publique
c'est ça voilà le mobile profonde 7 200
sa double mobilisation en grande
bretagne comme en france c'est quand
même davantage un
mobile qui en réfère à l'ordre public
c'est à dire qu' il n'est pas bon de
présenter le spectacle des animaux
souffrent ou agonisant sur la voie
publique ou d'animaux simplement en
butte aux brutalités décoché et autres
et autres individus qui sont en rapport
avec eux tout simplement parce que c'est
un ça peut être un ferment de désordre
de démoralisation au sens où
c'est mauvais pour la morale et la
morale populaire et ça peut provoquer
des révoltes et
ça provoque d'ailleurs des attroupements
des protestations en effet donc c'est
davantage au nom de l'ordre public que
au nom de la sensibilité animal que
qu'ont lieu ces mots néanmoins sur le
sec les animaux souffrent mais alors on
sait que les animaux sont intenses a
pensé qu'on a découvert ça récemment
mais le 19e siècle le l'intérêt pour
l'animal de compagnie c'est vraiment le
siècle découvre l'animal de compagnie et
on voit les animaux de compagnie à
devenir très très très très courant donc
on sait que l'animal l'animal souffre il
faut voir qu'on vivait beaucoup plus
près des animaux qu'aujourd'hui ne
serait ce que par la l'omniprésence des
chevaux dans les villes où il y avait
des prospectivistes qui pensaient que
paris serait recouvert les symptômes
voilà
deux creux on allait inventer le tome 1
c'est vrai que les projections nord
était recouvert de il ya un rapport avec
le monde animal qui est beaucoup plus
console il y en a partout il ya des
animaux absolument partout des abattoirs
au milieu des villes il faudra les
fermes et c de la peau les os 3 qui va
s'en occuper en tout cas les les réduire
en réduire le nombre mais les animaux
sont absolument partout
il ya là en 1829 jae bum 229 c'était une
dette importante les paysans français
résiste à la privatisation des forêts en
se déguisant on va appeler ça la guerre
des demoiselles et en enlevant des
agents de l'état
oui c'est une continuation en fait du
rapport de 18 ans atteints c'est pour ça
que vous y aviez pensé à la suite donc
de ses inquiétudes climatiques on va
décider d'établir un code forestier pour
mieux gérer les forêts justement
empêcher cette déforestation et
peut-être réduire les inondations dans
les plaines et c est les premiers
incriminés sont les montagnards on
estime qu' ils ne sont incapables de
gérer correctement les forêts des
montagnes qu'il coupe trop de forêt qui
laisse paître leurs bêtes qui habite qui
abîment les les pâturages et c'est donc
on va établir un code forestier qui est
très mal perçue évidemment par les
habitants des forêts des montagnes et
des forêts en général et qui ont un
besoin quotidien en fait de ces forêts
pour chercher du petit bois justement
des fois pour récupérer de quoi repaître
leurs animaux etc et donc cela va
entraîner de révolte notamment donc
cette guerre des demoiselles en ariège
et qui se traduit par ses déguisements
ces manifestations ces enlèvements ces
menaces de mort qui ne sont pas mises à
bien heureusement et qui font reculer
l'état en fait c'est à dire qu'on laisse
finalement un petit peu faire on laisse
les montagnards revenir à des pratiques
antérieures où ils pouvaient utiliser
quelque peu leurs forêts et là c'est une
victoire et une défaite pour
l'environnement
ça c'est une bonne question je dirais
que c'est une victoire parce que le
cette conception que les communautés
locales sont incapables de prendre soin
de leur environnement être une constante
en fait de va être utilisé pour la
colonisation et également voilà c'est ce
que je voulais dire tout à fait c'est
qu'on en dise qualifie donc les
communautés locales en disant voilà il
sera incapable de gérer les choses
correctement il faut faire intervenir la
puissance publique les autorités etc or
très souvent on constate quand même que
contrairement à ce qu'on veut faire
croire les communautés locales les gens
qui vivent au quotidien justement leur
environnement en prennent soin
ce moment est important il me semble à
aa2 titre d'une part parce que il marque
c'est un moment d'intervention de la
puissance publique via le code forestier
donc vraiment l'état intervient dans
dans la gestion du milieu et que la
réaction des des paysans locaux a été
perçue au moment-même comme la trace
d'un archaïsme la manifestation d'un
archaïsme voilà ils défendent un droit
coutumier qui est le droit de glanage or
la france est en train de se moderniser
il faut absolument sortir de cette
configuration là et je dirais que ça
c'est resté vrai le longtemps puisque
moi qui suis plus âgées que charles
françois quand j'ai quand j'ai fait mes
études d'histoire et qu'on nous parlait
de la guerre des demoiselles on
présentait cette révolte là vraiment
comme un de ces mouvements héritées de
l'ancien régime de protestation contre
l'autorité de l'état qu'ils étaient
gênés protestation contre l'impôt les
comptes alors voilà contre l'impôt et là
contre la la la la fin d'un droit
coutumier
de qui est elle donc le droit de glanage
et d'une forme d'autonomie locale du
coup et là une protestation contre la
centralisation aussi et contre les
effets de la centralisation dont contre
contre les effets de l' empire en
réalité c'est la suite à deux pas de
forestiers le premier espace protégé au
monde c'est la forêt de fontainebleau
est en 1861 dites vous dans ce livre on
est les premiers qui pensons à 7 ans on
a été prudent on a dit un des premiers
espaces protégés
voilà c'est par chauvinisme on
nous avait je n'avais pas trouvé de plus
anciens non plus
non mais alors ça c'est bon là c'est
sans doute faute de travaux aussi enfin
bon bien il faut rester prudent il faut
toujours être prudent quand on fait de
l'histoire avec la nouveauté
line l'inédit intégral bon alors
l'histoire de la forêt de fontainebleau
et sa protection et comme généralement
assez bien connu lula on doit cette
cette protection est ce ce classement à
la mobilisation des artistes des
peintres de l'école de barbizon qui qui
témoigne d'une sensibilité nouvelle à un
milieu naturel il faut mettre beaucoup
de guillemets naturel la forêt de
fontainebleau et
n'est pas dans son état d'origine c'est
évident mais voilà qui témoigne d'une
attention
d'une attention quand même nouvelle une
sensibilité à des paysages qui ne sont
pas parsemé de ruines ou de voilà dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas forcément alors
c'est pas le cas de l'illustration de
notre notice puisqu'il y ad ya des
hommes mais voilà le paysage pour
lui-même la beauté du lieu pour
elle-même y compris lorsqu'il ne s'agit
que de roches et d'arbres et ça c'est
nouveau on né en 1861 c'est il ya les
impressionnistes au même moment voilà
réunis ces endroits là il ya une
sensibilité à ce moment là qui est en
train de on est à la fin du second
empire et qui est enfin qui est en train
de s'installer et voit bien à l'égard de
la nature à l'égard de tout à fait qui
s'inscrit dans ce ski design claude la
construction en fait d'une peinture de
paysage avec les peintres de barbizon
coraux puis ensuite la filiation vers
l'est vers les impressionnistes mais ce
qui est intéressant aussi dans le cadre
de cette forêt de fontainebleau c'est
con on voit les motivations diverses qui
se manifeste pour la protéger ils sont
d'abord des raisons esthétiques lié donc
à ce casque anne-claude évoqué dans ce
regard paysager mais aussi des
motivations sanitaire hygiéniste qui
veulent protéger cet espace pour
permettre aux populations citadines
devenir si des lacets il respirait etc
et en l'occurrence surtout des
populations parisienne qui avait accès
depuis les années 40 par le chemin de
fer tout ça à jouer pour rendre cet
espace populaire et
suffire disons à ce que la pression
parisienne essentiellement fasse bouger
le pouvoir napoléonien il huppert et le
convaincre de protéger cet espace mais
avec des contradictions dire que d'un
côté les peintres voulait préserver cela
absolument pour leur inspiration et il
n'appréciait que très moyennement
évidemment de voir des touristes
débarqués tous les week-ends et
s'infiltre et un petit peu partout dans
le dans la forêt
j'ai dit au début les anglais sont
obsédés par la pollution pendant tout le
19e siècle c'est normal puisqu'ils ont
commencé leur révolution industrielle
avons nous donc ils en ont ils envoient
les les conséquences avant nous et ça se
cristallise beaucoup chez eux sur le
smog ou donnera le nom plus tard un vous
l'expliquera mais le brouillard à
londres c'est une vérité catastrophe et
ça va donner ce très beau tableau de
whistler d'ailleurs qui est un peu
impressionnistes on pourrait le croire
en tout cas et alors la pollution c'est
le fameux brouillard anglais c'est de la
fumée du sinn c'est la fumée du charbon
alors c'est la fumée de charbon oui
c'est d'abord la fumée du sinn est de
plus en plus la fumée des intérieurs
domestique c'est à dire que les
principaux responsables dans la deuxième
moitié du 19e siècle de la pollution de
londres ce sont les particuliers qui
brûlent du charbon dans des cheminées
qui sont pas adaptés explique que le
charbon se consuma les rejette donc
énormément de suivi dans l'atmosphère
c'est alors traditionnel c'est-à-dire
qu'on a déjà des plaintes concernant ces
émanations dès le moyen-âge pour
quelques-unes particulièrement à la
renaissance et puis ça revient au 19e
siècle avec l'extension de la ville et
l'accroissement de cet usage et le
londres donc commence à avoir cette
singularité disons du smog donc une
contraction de smoke fumée et fog
brouillard c'est un mot qui est créée en
1905 mais qui rappelle une réalité qui
existe depuis au moins un siècle donc et
ses brouillards sont vraiment terribles
c est là encore on n'imagine pas ce que
c'est
l'équivalent à mon avis ce qu'on voit en
chine quand on voit des images comme ça
de vol à vue
voilà exactement comme on le voit dans
les années 50 une des dernières grandes
manifestations du smog il a fallu
attendre ses vinyles morts pour que
enfin les autorités prennent les choses
en main résister d'aujourd'hui la
l'époque je trouvais comme david oui
mais c'est vraiment une purée de pois
qui empêche voire 1 mètre c'est à dire
qu des fois ne voyez pas de l'autre côté
de la rue donc tout est bloqué toute la
circulation toute l'activité économique
et est arrêté en plus ce brouillard a
donc une saveur particulière un petit
peu à cran le sang sur la langue il est
gras forcément puisque elle la suit donc
on le sent aussi sur les mains sur la
peau c'est vraiment une expérience très
particulière et qui a tiré les peintres
on a exprès voulu montrer sa dimension
esthétique parce que des peintres comme
monnaie qui venait exprès en fait à
londres dans les années 70 pour peindre
le brouillard et j'ai trouvé un jour une
citation de monnaie qui se plaignait
d'un beau jour à londres andy revenons
aujourd'hui a pas de brouillard je veux
rien faire c'est une 405 le brouillard
est pour beaucoup chez les
impressionnistes
il a favorisé car quasiment
l'impressionnisme et oscar wilde lui
aussi a eu vous savez on parle souvent
du fait qu'il ait dit que le c'est l'arc
c'était la nature qui imitent à l'art il
a dit notamment à propos du brouillard
de londres en disant ce brouillard
n'existe que depuis que les
impressionnistes ou les peintres nous
ont montré son existence
monet a peint d'ailleurs d'aider des
locomotives à vapeur voilà exactement
pour ça pour parce qu'il cherchait cette
espèce de skouma tôt produit par toutes
sortes de pollutions inquiets alors on
insiste beaucoup sur le brouillard
londonien ça peut partir des images
d'epinal pour un finir vous insistez
aussi dans votre livre sur la puanteur
qui règne à londres dès le début du
xixème siècle 1 c'est vraiment une ville
qui sans effroyablement mauvais est ce
que pourrait finir par y qui va beaucoup
alors lui aussi s'est industrialisée à
partir du second empire et à la fin du
second temps faim pendant le second
empire on est à la fois à new york et
bangkok 1 on est new york parce qu'on
est la ville lumière qui se passe
toujours quelque chose today mais on est
aussi la ville de la prostitution donc
est ce que pour autant paris pu comme
londres et est attribué à des
brouillards comme il y en a à londres
pas autant déjà les conditions
climatiques tout simplement sont pas les
mêmes londres est dans une cuvette et il
y a des brouillards naturel qui en suit
donc se combine aux émanations de fumée
pour créer le smoke donc paris n'est pas
dans la même situation tout simplement
topologique le charbon est moins
utilisée aussi et quand il l'a il est
utilisé dans des poêles qui le consume
correctement donc qui ne rejettent pas
autant de poussière et de fumée que
calandre dans une poêle dans un poêle
pardon c'est mieux que dans une cheminée
oui parce que le poil est fermée donc la
confiance se fait plus complètement et
les anglais ont toujours résisté en fait
aux poils parce qu'ils aimaient leur
foyer ouvert ce le feu voilà ouvert de
charbon qu'ils avaient peur maintenant
ils ont donc défaut exactement ils ont
plus droit c'est une abomination mais
qui donne aux défauts avec des fausses
flammes avait exactement ça va au delà
de 20 ans a été mis en place dans les
hutus tout début juste avant la première
guerre mondiale et puis surtout dans
l'entre-deux-guerres on voit apparaître
effectivement ces fameux feu électrique
et c'est vrai
l'idée selon laquelle en france les
usines enfin à paris les usines sont à
l'aise que justement pour pas que les
odeurs et la pollution viennent à
l'ouest où sont les belles demeures
c'étaient les quartiers chics puisque
les vents dominants du coup et écarte
écarte les les fumées malodorantes du
centre de paris née en moi je suis
d'accord enfin je pense que oui paris pu
reprendre vos mots et de toutes sortes
d'odeurs mélanger même si effectivement
c'est un une capitale qui est moins
soumises à la pollution mais qui parce
qu'il reste encore au 19e siècle au ciné
des industries artisanales pourrait-on
dire organique les tanneurs et c est
tout ça pue horriblement de la même
façon que paris est sans doute une ville
extrêmement bruyante légalement au 19e
siècle en raison même de ses activités
industrielles et artisanales et je pense
qu'on a du mal à se représenter ça
aujourd'hui mais aidés et des sabots des
chevaux et bien sûr lire d'araignée
voilà on est tous alors on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui la première une des
premières doléances en matière de vie
quotidienne à paris émises par les
parisiens concerne le bruit mais je
pense qu'on est loin du compte
oui à propos d de ces pollutions et de
ses mauvaises odeurs né des tanneries et
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que jusqu'au au milieu du 19e
siècle voire encore après ce sont elles
qui sont incriminés comme des pollutions
et non pas les émanations du sinn de
soudou de fumée de charbon qui au
contraire auquel on prêtait des vertus
désinfectantes dire que la théorie des
miasmes ne faisait que c'était ses
mauvaises odeurs de tannerie organique
qui risquait de provoquer des maladies
et donc de polluer et non pas et palaja
mis le paquet et étaient nettoyés par le
parlement l'invention de la chimie oui
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après on continue cette histoire des
luttes pour l'environnement
[Musique]
c'est un beau livre une histoire des
luttes pour l'environnement qui vient de
paraître chez textuel on continue d'en
parler avec anne claude de ambroise
rendu et charles françois matthys font
partie des quatre auteurs quatre
historiens qui ont écrit ce livre il ya
également steve à gimont et et alaixys
vrignon il ya une date qui est
importante c'est
1895 je crois c'est la publication de la
machine à explorer le temps de hg wells
il avait écrit quand il était très jeune
j'ai wells il avait 21 ans et son
premier livre mais il y en a de
plusieurs versions différentes qui vont
paraître et au fond ça c'est la décence
de la dystopie et la dystopie c'est très
important évidemment dans dans les
luttes pour l'environnement on va se
servir des dystopies de la science
fiction pour annoncer un monde
catastrophique et c'est ce que vous êtes
déjà j wells dans danseuse dans ce roman
là hein c'est pas vraiment la naissance
parce que en réalité hg wells prend la
suite d'une tradition et déjà des
délits milieu du 19e siècle ce qui
d'ailleurs est concordant avec tout ce
qu'on vient de dire c'est à dire que la
révolution industrielle et les
transformations qu'elle induit
suscite des inquiétudes ou en tout cas
sont sources d'inspiration
donc il ya il ya différentes dystopie
avant et qui sont des dystopies c'est à
dire des romans d'anticipation des
romans du genre futur comment les
appelle d'ailleurs qui présente toujours
une terre dévastée dans laquelle il est
devenu très difficile voire impossible
pour pour l'humanité de vivre je pense
notamment aux romands de reus ni l'aîné
le l'auteur de de la guerre du feu six
ans plus tard continue mais lens et
c'est à peu près au même moment mais y
en avait eu d'autres avant et kim qui
montre une terre à l'agonie sur laquelle
le dernier humain c'est certain la fin
du roman donc or vous disiez bas c'est
un élément important de deux cellules en
réalité ça a été strictement me
semble-t-il sans effet voilà c'est de la
littérature oui on n'y croit pas on n'y
croit pas puisque puisque ce sont des
romans et que la littérature a des
visées de distraction n'y crois pas les
autorités n'y crois pas parce qu'elles
sont pas envie d'y croire mais le
lecteur lui les croix alors évidemment
que la question de la réception de la
stabilité assez assez qu'aux jeunes est
aussi gras bien entendu et bien entendu
ça travaille quelque chose de deux dents
lors des représentations à des
sensibilités quelque chose
vraisemblablement d' assez profond et
puis il y aura d'autres dystopie ensuite
et le succès croissant des dystopies
montre quelque chose en effet quand même
marché
mais bon ça va pas changer grand chose
aux choix politiques qui ont été faits
en matière de gestion de la nature et de
l'écologie et de pollution dans les deux
cas d'ailleurs istomin dystopie mes
utopies aussi on n'a pas pu le penser un
futur aux entrepôts à la même moment à
la fin du dix neuvième siècle en
angleterre il n'ya pas effectivement kg
wells ya eu toute une à partir des
années 1870 toute une série de décrit
d'anticipation qui anticipe donc un
futur catastrophiste ou non et qui
permet de penser notamment la transition
énergétique alors il ne formule pas dans
de cette manière là mais il imagine un
futur où le charbon ne serait plus
dominant alors en général il est
remplacé par l'électricité sans
s'interroger de la manière dont on
produit l'électricité bien sûr et quand
ils envisagent le pire alors là du coup
effectivement tout est détruit par le
charbon et par les mouvements produit
par le charbon mais on on a donc une
réflexion positive ou négative et qui
pénètre limites de la science pas les
milieux politiques c'est vrai mais où on
voit des scientifiques s'interrogaient
eux mêmes sur la manière dont on
pourrait transformer le monde et
notamment le royaume uni autour des
énergies pour essayer de de changer un
peu cette foule de charbon à une aussi
mauvaise image quasiment ou du 19e
siècle que le pétrole au 20e oui à cela
s'ajoute en plus les conditions de vie
des mineurs par exemple et des accidents
qui peuvent en découler exactement à la
différence prêt pour le royaume-uni qu'
il ya une espèce de c'est je t'aime moi
non plus en fait avec le charmant parce
que on y tient énormément c'est le
fondement de la puissance du pays c'est
ce feu de charbon que j'évoquais
auparavant dans les intérieurs qui est
tellement essentiel disons à la aux
sentiments du rom sweet home donc il y
as cet attachement finalement très très
fort qu'on apprend en fait tout jeune à
l'école à la maison et en même temps
cette conscience que c'est une source
d'énergie qui est épuisable et qui en
plus détruit les atmosphères la santé et
eu depuis 1880 on reconnaît sa dimension
létale et dans cet optimisme du côté
français on a le roman de jules verne
paris 1900 paraissant qui présente une
ville propre ne justement nettoyé de ses
miasmes et c'est par la vertu de
l'électricité il faudra attendre
barjavel avec ravages pour qu'on ait un
roman qui montre que l'électricité ne
résout pas les problèmes 43 oui c'est 52
je crois enfin bon peu importe le jules
verne est vraiment le un excellent
représentant de ce point de vue il de ce
point de vue de la foi qui continue
quand même d'animer majoritairement les
gens à l'égard des progrès réalisable
par la science qui vont permettre
progressivement de répondre aux
questions posées par l'industrie a parlé
pollution ça va se maintenir cette
idéologie regrets elle va se bâtir s'est
longtemps c'est seulement maintenant que
quasiment ça s'est inversé et fait je ne
suis pas sûre que
l'inversion soit totale enfin il semble
dans les populations quand même sur le
plan des pratiques pas tellement non et
on entend encore quand même un certain
nombre de gens vous dire que à se
répondre à des à des questions
ponctuelles parce que je pensais au
diesel bon que les scientifiques vont
trouver la solution pour que le diesel
finissent par ne plus être polluants non
je crois qu'à points dans le second les
scientifiques ont trouvé des solutions
en matière de en matière de déchets par
exemple ils n'ont pas trouvé grand chose
1 je pense à la fois aux déchets
plastiques ou aux déchets radioactifs
pour l'instant on ne sait on ne sait pas
les traiter on ne sait pas quand faire
bon à l'ensemble d'ailleurs des déchets
industriels à part les enfouir dans un
grand tour on ne sait pas la science n'a
pas réponse à tout jusqu'à présent on
n'a pas eu de réponse à tout c'est ce
qu'on peut dire je suis entièrement
d'accord mais cette question du progrès
elle est au coeur aussi nos
interrogations dans l' ouvrage puisque
c'est un peu elle qui a rythmé les
quatre partis qu'on a autour desquels on
a organisé nos notices ce qui nous a
donné bien du mal d'ailleurs parce que
on voulait absolument sortir de l'idée
d'un récit où comme vous le disiez au
tout début d'émission tout d'un coup
dans les années 70 donc en conscience
qu' il ya des problèmes environnementaux
on voulait sortir de cette vision
linéaire en fait de l'histoire en
montrant qu'il ya donc des phases d
alerte très tôt qui sont entendus ou pas
qui agissent ou pas mais en tout cas ce
qui est clair c'est que le on a on reste
encore accrochée à ses idées de progrès
et malgré tout à partir de des années la
fin des années 60 1960 70 ce progrès est
plus contestée des façons plus plus
organisés plus philosophique aussi en
quelque sorte est aussi plus plus
concrète par des actions et aussi par
une prise de conscience des apories du
système industriel et par la jeunesse
même qui était ce qui est une vraie
révolution parce que la jeunesse a
priori et est en phase avec le progrès
elle l'espère elle l'attend elle pense
qu'elle en profitera celle-là
déstabilise pas comme ça déstabilise les
générations plus âgées qui ont grandi
sans ce progrès la lie à un retournement
à partir de là des années 60 oui bah ya
ce moment 68 très très clair qu'on a
voulu marquer justement en lui accordant
quasiment une partie entière parce qu'on
a au tournant de ces années 60 70
une
concentration en fait d'événements et de
phénomènes qui sont liées à des luttes
mais aussi à d'autres autre aspect le on
en a pas parlé je crois mais le lever de
terre vue depuis la navette apollo 8 en
1968 bien sûr va jouer aussi dans une
cour la première fois on voyait la terre
photographiée voit l'arrivée j'avais vu
exactement dont on percevait cette
espèce de bulle de vie absolument
magnifique dans l'immensité de l'espace
donc toute sa fragilité et l'unité de
l'humanité assas a eu et dont tout lé
toutes les autres considérations
finalement paraissait bien bien
marginale et bien c'est drôle parce que
tout le monde s'en souvient en dix ans
on a vu sa fragilité moi j'étais tout
petit mais je me souviens aussi de ces
images et aux contrats chez twist est le
seul endroit où il ya de la couleur
ces tribus m'apparaissait contraire
invincible la terre sur ces photos elle
était colorée habité vivante tout le
reste a clairement
et raison de plus pour pour la protéger
pour la conserver en l'état mais bon je
pars une question de sensibilité et puis
j'étais vraiment tout petit vous le
passez vous en parliez tout à l'heure
la colonisation qui se fait aussi pour
des motifs environnementaux notamment en
afrique d'ailleurs et ça continue
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs où on a chassé
les populations des grandes réserves où
on accueille des touristes et les
populations se retrouvent chasse est
parce que l ça fait ça fait du désordre
écologique qu'aient liban tout à fait
c'est un peu ce qu'on évoquait
auparavant propos des montagnards les
l'une des justifications la colonisation
était de dire bon ces populations ont
laissé dégrader l'environnement en
afrique du nord par exemple on a des
déserts la houssoye dix ans auparavant
des forêts luxuriantes poucet c'est dû
au nomadisme c'est dû à des pratiques
qui sont néfastes à l'environnement nous
occidentaux puissances européennes nous
allons agir et protéger ces espaces et
on le fait en là encore en effectivement
en excluant les personnes d'aider les
personnes qui vivaient là de ces espaces
en les empêchant d'y avoir accès en
créant des réserves forestières et en
les gérant de façon qu'on estime
rationnelle souvent d'ailleurs en
faisant des plantations qui sont qui
appauvrissent la biodiversité locale et
donc en créant des tensions très très
locale est très vive avec les
populations qui est encore été privés de
leur subsistance et sur le long terme
exact témoigne d'une vision sur tombante
de ce que sont ces populations et qui
sont jugées comme étant incapable
finalement de maintenir le milieu en
l'état et encore une fois d'une d'une
représentation ce scientifique aux
scientifiques de la façon dont il faut
quand il faut
et sur le long terme ça a été une
catastrophe ou finalement
on ne me suis pas trop mal débrouillé
on
sait pas trop mal débrouillé au sens où
de grandes réserves ont été créées qui
ont malgré tout protéger ce qui reste
est mais souvent ces réserves notamment
pour les réserve animale elles ont été
créées après avoir décimé des
populations entières de d'éléphants ou
de de lyon où d'autres et où on s'est
rendu compte donc il fallait quand même
qui peut apprendre à lever le pied si on
voulait qu'il en reste pour des
chasseurs donc les premières réserves
ont été créés en fait parce qu'on
appelle les bouchers repenti il ya une
association débouchés repenti donc
d'anciens chasseurs qui massacrait des
animaux par dizaines et qui ont décidé
que pour permettre des pratiques de
chasse perpétuer on devait d'avoir des
réserves alors ensuite elles ont un peu
évolué moment des indépendances ou au
début du 20e siècle lorsque ont commencé
à critiquer de plus en plus justement
ces pratiques de chasse mais à l'origine
elles ont été créées pour répondre à des
destructions fait parler d'eux et au
prix de déplacements de populations
oui je suis là sur la qu'il faudrait
poser la question de la catastrophe ou
pas oui
la découverte de l' influence humaine
sur l'effet de serre sa date de 1896
disposiez l'usure tout à l'heure c'est
un s'est vanté arrhenius qui obtiendra
le prix nobel de chimie en 1903 à ce
moment là on se rend compte qu'il ya des
choses c'est ce qu'on voit sur l'image
qui figure dans le livre il ya des
phénomènes naturels
mais on qu'on n'arrive pas à expliquer
est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'ils découvrent arrhenius à ce moment
là en fait il vient à elle en vient à
comprendre que le lait la température du
globe dépend en partie de la
concentration de co2 et comme on avait
cette conscience quand même de de la
projection de co2 dans l'atmosphère par
l'usagé croissant du charbon depuis un
siècle il se doutait bien disons qu'une
corrélation devait exister et que des
risques de modification du climat
pourrait se produire on comprend ce
qu'est l'atmosphère à ce moment là oui
oui on a une meilleure compréhension
façon le 19e siècle va apporter cela
c'est à dire que
c'est le siècle de l'eau de la science
par excellence qui permet de comprendre
avec beaucoup plus de précision
les phénomènes naturels l'écologie n'est
aussi à ce moment là elle devient une
science véritablement qui a conscience
d'elle-même à la toute fin du 19e siècle
et en lien notamment avec l'exploration
impérial dire que on a pénétré ces
territoires on a découvert des tas de
biotope d'écosystèmes nouveau etc et on
en est venu à mieux comprendre les
interactions entre plantes entre animaux
et plantes là les actions de l'homme sur
ces espaces et donc à partir de là une
science écologique a pu voir le jour
en
48 et fondée sous les auspices de
l'unesco là on est en dise au xxème
siècle un il ya eu beaucoup de choses
entre les deux mais je me suis arrêté
sur les ceux qui m'ont paru le plus
frappant à fontainebleau encore ont créé
l'union internationale pour la
protection de la nature c'est la
première instance internationale crée
alors un oeuf pas vraiment en fait le
elle est vraiment là l'héritière d'un
d'une série de congrès pour la
protection de la nature qui sont tenues
dans l'antre 2 dans la trop de guerre
est un petit peu à voir la première
guerre mondiale en 1909 on a un grand
congrès à la protection des paysages et
le mot est important s'il s'agit pas de
protéger la nature en tant que tel mais
bien des paysages et il n'a pas vraiment
fait de suite où c'est un peu compliqué
disons de de suivre ses conséquences et
en 1913 il ya un ancêtre direct de
scène et qui est une commission créée à
berne explicitement pour la protection
de la nature cette fois mais évidemment
1913 on est un an avant la première
guerre mondiale la guerre a lieu et tout
ça tombe à l'eau il faut attendre
ensuite 1923 et 1931 pour que deux
congrès à nouveau se tiennent à paris et
cette fois leur titre est intéressant
puisque ce sont des congrès pour le
premier pour la protection des paysages
de la faune et de la flore dire que la
dimension scientifique de la protection
de la nature pénètre à ce moment là et
le rôle des scientifiques
et plus important ils remplacent peu à
peu les artistes en fête dans les
motivations et les acteurs disons delà
de la protection de la nature et lui ce
n8 peine d'abord puis vie saine à
lorsqu'elle est créée en 48 est un peu
l'héritière donc de ceux de ce mouvement
et de cette scientifique isation
croissante disons la protection de la
nature elle veut avoir une efficacité
bah elle prend surtout acte du fait que
les phénomènes de destruction de la
planète sont des phénomènes globaux
planétaire olaf justement qu'il s'agit
bien de la planète et que on ne peut
plus se contenter de luttes locales de
contestation locales ou que du moins il
faut que ces comptes et donc c'est dans
la foulée de l'unesco mais aussi
d'ailleurs sur disney ou en fait on se
rend compte que on peut il faudrait une
gouvernance mondiale masse et la gala
commence à naître et elle a un rôle
important aussi qui sur un thème qui est
important aussi pour aujourd'hui qui est
celui de l'information et des données
elle réunit en fait une dizaine de
milliers d'experts je crois à travers le
monde là en l'occurrence sur les aspects
purement biologique l elfe calcul les
espèces menacées et celles qui sont sur
le point de disparaître et c'est donc à
elle donne des faits concrets précis
scientifiques incontestables et or la
maîtrise de l'information on le voit
encore aujourd'hui bien sûr est un
élément central des luttes et de ceux
qui veulent empêcher les avancées
environnementales alors rachel carson
voudrait qu'on s'arrête sur elle parce
qu'elle a un peu oublié en tout cas en
france chez patients aux états unis on
s'en souvient davantage en étant 1962
elle fan énorme best-seller
international avec silent spring dans
lequel elle dresse elle fait le bilan de
tous les maux qui menacent la terre est
sain
un retentissement absolument
considérable à l'époque je crois que la
cour suprême des etats unis il dit que
c'est le document le plus important de
l'histoire de l'humanité et elle joue
vraiment un rôle elle joue surtout un
rôle dans la dans la prise de conscience
est franchement mais en même temps c'est
un rôle à double détente parce que dans
le moment même où la cour suprême
effectivement senti fille en quelque
sorte ce document comme étant
d'importance
d'un pick-up capital merci rachel carson
sans doute aussi parce qu'elle est une
femme et et maltraité par les médias et
maltraité par une partie du public qui
voit en elle une espèce de deux bons
voire à deux femmes un peu hystérique
cas mois lena contre oui oui tout à fait
sauf que rachel carson alors je ne dis
pas que greta tune berg et illégitime
dans dans ses prises de position bien au
contraire mais rachel carson et qui plus
est une scientifique de renom ou et qu
elle sait de quoi elle parle spécialiste
des océans voilà équipe usée elle
propose des solutions donc c'est pas du
tout ça n'est pas un brûlot cela n'est
pas un pamphlet ça n'est pas un livre de
protestation c'est un livre de
propositions
et c'est là justement qu'on voit
l'importance de encore une fois de ses
aspects scientifiques de ces données
elle a été disqualifiée comme tu le
disais part parce que femme parce que l
avancée des éléments pourtant étayées
scientifiquement mais qui n'étaient pas
acceptables pour nombre de scientifiques
qui mettait en scène un scrutin
l'industrie dans difficulté bien sûr est
la vôtre et agroalimentaire c'est aussi
ce qu'on lui reprochait faible
semble-t-il c'est son pessimisme aussi
c'est à dire qu'on en revient on a
confiance dans le progrès on dit qu'on
trouvera toujours une solution et au
fond ceux qui sont trop pessimistes ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les effondre
east les collabos log et on aurait pu la
traiter de ça à ce moment là même si
elle trouvait des nems ciel de l donner
des solutions en fait ça passe pas très
souvent je lis bon oui bien sûr il faut
pas continuer comme ça mais on trouvera
bien un moyen oui ça passe pas comme si
l'observation simplement un cessez de
l'observation qu'elle fait l'observation
de ce qui n était pas suffisante pour
convaincre oui
il ya quelque chose qui va peut-être
participer de la conviction qu'on va se
faire que l'environnement est important
c'est le naufrage du torrey canyon en
1967 en bretagne la marée noire là aussi
moi j'étais enfant je vois ça c'est un
vrai souvenir des les images qu'on
voyait ces images là donc on retrouve
dans votre niveau ça ça frappe vraiment
la population française oui parce que
c'est très vite
médiatisé alors là je vois la voix on
voit les vite et là on trouve être à
l'éviter mais on
sait aussi les possibilités
technologiques des médias qui
permettent cette médiatisation massive
et parce qu'on voit bien là avec l'image
du macareux enduit d'un enduit de
pétrole que on a pris conscience à la
fois encore une fois ma roue
c'est une histoire de prise de
conscience qui ne cesse pas de se
renouveler s'inquiète un peu terrible
donc on s'est bien rendu compte que en
effet
le lait pollution était liée aussi
à l'état du commerce international voilà
la marée noire et puis
deuxième élément c'est elle la
sensibilisation
via ces images d'animaux englués dans le
pétrole qui ont dont beaucoup sont morts
et puis de la mobilisation des bretons 1
ils sont venus nettoyer ses plages avec
ce qui leur tombait sous la main c'est à
dire des pelles des râteaux des enfin
maroilles et qui sont venus essayer de
sauver ceux se ses oiseaux et là on a un
macareux or le macareux c'est une mue
c'est un emblème de la protection de la
nature puisque il l'a été
il a été l'objet d'une protection aux
personnes 1912 sous l'effet de l'action
de la lpo dans les sept îles donc bon il
y avait voilà je crois que c'est cette
double un passionné là on voit bien tout
va s'enchaîner un là on se rapproche des
années 70 dans les années 70 à la
résistance contre les voies rapides dans
paris il y avait des projets l époque
pour qu'une autoroute arrive de d'orly à
la gare montparnasse par exemple trois
ou quatre voix il ya les les voies
express la voie express rive gauche que
anne hidalgo a fini par fermer il ya eu
encore beaucoup de protestations moment
elle l'affirmé mais il ya déjà des
protestations à l'époque quand on la
construit oui tout à fait et le si je
peux juste revenir sur la marée noire en
lien avec ce qu'on vient de dire ici
c'est la marée noire avait cet intérêt
aussi de relier le global au local c'est
qu'on voit là on avait un phénomène lié
donc au commerce international comme tu
le disais au poids du pétrole dans le
dans le monde et qu'ils avaient un
impact direct sur les bretons et je
crois qu'on a mis une une image parmi
les gens qui enlève le pétrole d'une
bretonne avec sa coiffe et c'est
important justement parce que on voit
l'impact local précis sur le quotidien
des gens deux phénomènes multi
multinationaux et globaux et en fait
pour ce qui est de des voies rapides
alors là c'est une lutte vraiment
purement locale mais ni s'inscrit bien
sûr dans une conception générale de la
modernité du tout-automobile de la
rapidité à tout crin et on ne peut que
remercier pour ceux qui habitent paris
ceux qui ont lutté contre s'est laissée
libre à nous on fait des grands films
sur les embouteillages sur
est-ce que ça s'inscrit contraint à une
conception de la ville qui était
vraiment le projet pompidolien là il
fallait aménager la ville pour l'ouvrir
aux voitures harvey dent paris n'avait
pas été conçu pour accueillir d d d d
automobiles à pétrole et donc c'est une
mobilisation qui n'a pas d'intérêt que
local parce que elle elle force les
individus les citadins à s'interroger
sur la ville qu'ils veulent dans quelle
ville est ce qu ils veulent vivre est-ce
qu'il faut que cette ville soit traversé
par des autoroutes urbaines et il ya
aussi les premières révoltes contre les
déchets en plastique il ya même des
manifestations dans les années 70 contre
les déchets en plastique au fond tout ce
dont nos conversations nos polémiques
aujourd'hui sont alimentés en ce qui
concerne l'environnement c'était déjà là
un avant avant avant le grand tournant
avant la candidature de rené dumont
comme comme premier candidat écologiste
en 1974 avant mad max le film tout ça
après ça va s'enchaîner mais il ya déjà
est déjà là des révoltes weeds est en
tout cas des inquiétudes des dès les
années 1950 d'ailleurs le passage au des
bouteilles en verre ou bouteilles en
plastique par exemple ne s'est pas fait
naturellement il ya beaucoup de débats
au sein même des entreprises sur
l'opportunité de faire cela des
inquiétudes déjà sur ce qu'on allait
faire de ces de ces bouteilles et des
réflexions déjà sur le recyclage
possible qu'ils n'ont pas forcément été
la machine qu'on voit là d'ailleurs et
c'est ça oui c'est ça voilà c'était pour
récupérer effectivement le plastique
ouvert
ou le métal mais on n'est pas encore du
tout il faut se souvenir aussi qu'avant
que ces bouteilles en plastique les
bouteilles étaient au vert on les
rapporte l effet la consigne claire il
fallait les rapporter c'était lourd
l'avantagé des bouteilles en plastique
sur un besoin de les rapporter que c'est
beaucoup plus oui tout à fait le mais on
n'est pas du tout encore évidemment à
une réflexion comme celle d'aujourd'hui
on perçoit la présence de
microparticules de plastique partout il
n'y a plus un espace sur la terre qui
échappait à ça hélas est l'une de nos
déceptions disons dans le livre qui
magnifiquement illustré et c'est qu'on
aurait aimé avoir une image qui
représentait des sacs en plastique sous
sous l'eau qui flottait comme des
méduses est vraiment quand on prêtait me
prenez pas attention on avait
l'impression que c'était des êtres
vivants et ça symbolise est justement
parfaitement cette base on côtoie la
globalisation des phénomènes
environnementaux et cette immixtion du
plastique dans tous les espaces et le
fait que le recyclage n'est pas une
solution parce que nous le rappelons
dans la notice le recyclage ne concerne
que 9% de la production globale de
plastique que donc c'est très peu de
chose et que ça ne se règle pas cette
question du déchets de plastique est un
qui est un déchet éternel
les années 70 tout va s'accélérer
c'est le larzac et le massacre des bébés
phoques
médiatisé par brigitte bardot c'est
greenpeace
là ça va plus s'arrêter là
non effectivement là on rentre dans une
dans une phase d'accélération de
cristallisation en fait des mouvements
beaucoup de choses éparses eux finissent
par se rejoindre se coaguler se traduire
aussi par donc des us des associations
très militante que vous avez cités les
amis de la terre aussi d'autres et par
un engagement politique aussi ce qui est
quand même la mort de la décroissance
aussi
tout de suite enfin il me semble que là
il faut regarder la chronologie de
manière un peu plus fine les années 70
sont un moment d'accélération
d'intensification et il me semble
qu'elles ont été suivies par une espèce
de reflux dans les caractérise les
années 80 et 90 et paradoxalement ce
reflux et contemporain de l'entrée en
politique c'est à dire dans le jeu
électoral des différents partis vers
ya eu comme une démobilisation de d
il y temps ordinaire devient plus plus
fortement avec le 21e alary mais cette
démobilisation explique effectivement
comme tu le dis sans doute l'entrée en
politique d'hier il a fallu un peu
compensé que d'une certaine manière ce
cet essoufflement associatif et militant
pour embellir al'inverse
aussi effectivement certains le font une
histoire des luttes pour l'environnement
ça vient de paraître chez textuel
martienne que de nombreux grands du
mercy chaque françois matthys merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]